Now I'm in Joshua Tree.
Where am I?
Yeah.
Now, I can definitely tell
that you are not able to see me.
You appear
when I look at you,
you begin to sort of like ghost
and a little thing.
Oh, I'm a ghost.
Yeah, you're ghost.
You're you. Hello?
It's just me
and your virtual land paying you a visit.
That is our next guest
having some fantastic Apple's new vision
pro headset.
Apple's first
mixed reality
headset blends digital content
into the literal space around us.
And today,
you can get it yourself for 3500 bucks.
Joining us now is senior
editor at large Scott Stein,
who is Test driving this gadget
literally right now.
You can see it.
His avatar is going to join us.
Scott, can I start with the device?
For sure I have.
Who is this
gear tour
before we get into what it actually does?
Who is this geared toward?
Who's buying it?
It's a great question.
I mean, Apple's
writing a line
between professionals
and the general consumer market.
And I think
if you're a professional,
you know, if you're looking at something
that needs a super high res display
or you're someone who knows
about creating and VR
or 3D models, maybe training that area,
but then if you're there
pitching as a super cinema
headset to the average person,
now $4,500, that's a lot of money.
But, you know, the experience in
it is phenomenal.
It's just that
that is an ultra luxury price territory.
It is in.
There's some question about, you know,
there aren't as many apps right now.
We're also which point of us your avatar
on the other side,
those who are wondering why
there's two screens and two Scotts
and that's what happened
and I'm fascinated by this
because I know it's a little bit heavy.
It has this giant battery.
And I'm picturing myself,
as you point out,
if you're watching a movie
or maybe if you're watching sports, too,
I might just
I just sit there on my couch with this.
I mean, you can't get up and walk
around with it or can you?
You can.
So the only thing
is that there's a battery pack.
So you have to carry that
in your pocket or something
or put it in a holder.
But you can actually walk around
with this.
And the pass through
cameras are good enough
that you can basically do
a lot of things.
I would not recommend
cooking or doing anything
mission critical.
But, you know,
you could definitely check the time.
You could check messages even.
It looks like you're looking at life
through a camera feed,
but you know,
that means you could also multitask.
You could run things on multiple monitors
in this
and check things in the outside world,
which is the feeling
of some sort of science
fiction world that I would be living in.
You expand on that a little bit.
Erica is tech
savvy and has covered this stuff
in the past.
I am not decades ago
before this existed, trying to be
if you're
purchasing this, what your goal,
what you're looking at right now,
what you're seeing right now,
what you're participating in right now,
explain it to a normal person.
Absolutely.
So what I've set up
is that I'm talking on my laptop at home,
which I can see through the
through the through one connection.
But I'm also connected
via video chat on Vision Pro.
So I see the two floating together.
It's like I'm sitting in the office.
I can see everything in the office,
but I'm also seeing a floating monitor
that's doing that connection.
And then what you're seeing
is my persona.
That's a scanned virtual identity card,
like an avatar that Apple uses
for for voice connections.
And it automatically works
with things like WebEx, Skype,
Zoom, Face Time, which it is a computer.
I mean,
they're talking
about as a spatial computer.
It's much more hooked in
to everything
that you might be doing with iOS
than any sort of VR headset before.
So it's a computer on your face
that looks like giant ski goggles
In reality, you know,
this is sort of
you were saying
when Phil asked
was just my main question to
who is this for? Right.
Early adopters, people
with some money to throw around.
What is this become that right?
So if this is the first thing
that we're going to see ultimately
for on a more accessible front,
what could that look like for the
average consumer?
Yeah.
So there was there's
been talk for years
and I've covered this landscape
looking at this mission
to get to air glasses,
you know,
like those Tony Stark glasses,
something futuristic
that we've seen in so many films
that shows you.
Heads up displays and you can,
you know,
see holograms
in the real world
and model them and all that.
But I think that also means melting
the idea of what's a computer
into something
that becomes virtual
that you can interact
with with your hands.
And a lot of people talked about
this literally being a vision
for what's there.
And I think that's what it is.
It lists the best possible model
to get that experience.
Obviously, in a
in a VR like design with a battery pack
but what it's doing blending realities
is pretty amazing
because there's been nothing at this size
that has done that.
There's been nothing
that's done
that with Hand-tracking in the air
like that altogether.
And I've looked at almost everything.
So I think once you do that in glasses,
you could potentially use
that for simulations.
For training, for,
you know, looking for helping
someone fix something
and guiding them through things
in the real world or assistance.
There's like so many wild ideas there,
but we're only like we're only at the
at the very beginning,
even after all this time.
Yeah, it is wild.
It certainly is.
Avatar slick and slick.
Scott, great to have you with us
this morning. Thank you, Scott.